みなさんこんにちははじめしゃちょーです
皆さんは高齢
術と呼ばれるもの
信じますでしょうか日本で有名な高齢術と
いえば人にかくれんぼとか結構有名なん
ですけれども今日はそんな高齢術の
海外で有名な高齢術をこのはじめしゃ
ちょーの3億円のお家の中でやってみたい
と思いますただいま時刻がですね深夜の
もうすぐ19時になる前ぐらいですどう
いう高齢術かというと結構場所を選ぶん
ですけれども
サイトとかでは海外版一人かくれんぼと
言われているぐらいかなり
有名な高齢者の一つになって
ます椅子の音が怖い
その名も3
キングス3人の王様って書いてスリー
キングスですね海外の掲示板に投稿された
ことから
海外で人気となった心霊術都市伝説系の
危険な遊びです
でなぜ日本でそんなにポピュラーじゃない
かと言うと日本の家だと
条件を満たせる場所が少ないので日本では
あんまりやられてないみたいなんですよ
はい俺の家はいはじめ社長のおうち全然
日本らしくないむしろアメリカアメリカ
サイズのお家なのでこのようなできる
だろうということでせっかくこんな家を
持っているのであればやりたいと思います
やりたいと思ってないんですけどもやら
なければいけない気はして
だけど高齢受付の儀式なので実際に行おう
と思っている人は最新の注意を払って
くださいと書いてありますなるほどね
やばいなレイヤー悪魔をその場で降ろして
しまう儀式であるということでかなり
リスクがあるらしいですこの3キングス
やる条件として屋根裏部屋とか地下室とか
静かで窓がない部屋がダメらしくてはい
地下室ありますせっかくこの地下室がない
とできない効率って地下室あるのでやら
なきゃいけないと思いますもう一つ
友人や恋人といった自分と親しい人間これ
なぜ必要かというと儀式を終わらせるため
に第三者の介入が必要不可欠のためらしい
です
これは絶対に欠かせないものらしくて
付き合いが6年ぐらいあるもう結構長い間
俺は結構信頼してます
ケンスケという後輩を呼んでおります
よろしくお願いします何かあったらマジで
頼んだよ本当に何かないでほしい
動画的にやってほしいそしてあとはもの
ですね水の入ったバケツライター1時間
以上
燃焼する
ろうそくマグカップ
扇風機またはサーキュレーター
椅子を3つ大きな
鏡を2枚
目覚まし時計スマートフォンか携帯電話
そして最後に
幼少期から大事にしているおもちゃこちら
を準備してください
最後がやばいねそして3キングスのやり方
説明していきますあもうそろそろ準備し
なきゃいけないですねまずは午後の11時
23時から準備を始めますちょうど11時
になってるのでそろそろ始めていきたいと
思いますあとは実際に準備しながら説明し
ていきましょうでは
無事に終わることを祈ります
今家にはポテト結石しかいませんこの部屋
か
はいここが地下室があるお部屋です必要な
もの一応一式準備してやりますこれで
大丈夫
しかし下げていきたいと思います
[音楽]
開きました地獄への門が
マジでやる
[音楽]
止めるならいますよ
そうだよやります
じゃあ行ってきますこれ以上って結局これ
メンタルの問題だと思うんだよね
精神的にバグると負けたと思ってるから
そこだけ俺の強さなんだよ精神
負ける気はしないと負ける
[拍手]
はいというわけで地下室来ましたで
椅子を3つ持ってきました1つはこれです
ねこれが自分が俺が座る椅子玉座になり
ます
玉座は北向きこっち向きに置きますでこの
玉座から手が届く範囲の左右に残り2つの
Sを向かい合わせになるように置きます
つまり俺が超えて座って手が届く範囲で
椅子2つ置けばいいのでこれ狙ってます
この2つの椅子が
愚か者と女王の
椅子となります
鏡を置きます
[音楽]
鏡の奥に俺がいるやばい次に
玉座の後ろに
扇風機かサーキュレーターを押して
ジャックから中の強さに設定して動かして
おきます一応両方あるんですけども扇風機
にしておきますこれを玉座の後ろに置き
ます
弱で動くようにしておきました
背中寒いやばい
[音楽]
めっちゃ寒い
精神的にやばいんだよこれそして次に手の
届かない距離に水の入ったバケツと近くに
マグカップを置きます水の入ったバケツ
です
自分の届かないところでしょう
ここに置いとこう
届かないOkマグカップですこれをバケツ
の近くに置いておきますこれで地下室は
準備完了です電気を消して部屋の扉を開け
たまま寝室に移動します
[音楽]
開けっ放しで寝室に向かいます
[拍手]
[音楽]
はい寝室に来ましたここからなんです
けれども目覚まし時計のアラームを午前3
時にセットします
[音楽]
えなんでなったの今意味わかんない
許してほしい午前3時半にセットスマホと
ライターとローソク自分が子供の頃から
大事にしてるおもちゃなどを持ったまま
眠りますで寝て午前3時半に俺起きます
起きたらナイターで火をつけたろうそくと
スマホを持って
儀式の部屋に戻ります地下室ですねここで
大事なんですけれどもスマホ
携帯電話が充電できていないまたは3時
33分までに
儀式の部屋にたどり着けない場合には
必ずその場で儀式を中断してください
儀式の部屋に到着したらろうそくの火が
消えないように注意して
玉座に座りますこの時もなんですけど開け
ていた扉が閉まっているという現象が発生
している場合はすぐに儀式を中断一緒に
儀式に参加してる親しい人間とすぐその場
を離れ一緒に家を出た後午前6時以降に家
に戻ってきてくださいこれが中断する方法
なんでしょうねで無事に玉座に吸われたら
鏡やろうそくの方は水に
正面の暗闇一点を見つめ質問を投げかけ
ます
そうすると両隣の愚か者か女王から
質問の答えが聞こえてくるらしいです
[音楽]
では3時半まで寝ますおやすみなさい
おやすみ寝すぎたらどうしよう普通にこれ
失敗なんだけど3分で下まで行かなきゃ
いけない結構むずいんですよね頑張ります
おやすみ
寝れるわけないでしょ声もどうやってねえ
んだよこの精神状態で
[音楽]
何の音だ
急げ
急げ急げ
急げ急げ急げ
急げ急げこれ聞いたらどうすんのこれ聞い
たらどうするの待って消えちゃう消え
ちゃう消えちゃう消えちゃうって待って
やばい消しちゃダメ
急げちょっと待って急げ急げ急げ急げ
急げ急げ
寝る場所ミスった絶対4回じゃなかった
入りますやばい
行ってきます
ちょっと待ってマジでやばいただ間に合っ
てるOk
[音楽]
俺はここから1時間
北の方向だけを一手に見つめます
絶対に鏡を見てはいけないし
ろうそくの火も消してはいけないそして
質問すると横の鏡から答えが返ってくる
みたいです
質問してみます
これ
結婚できます
[音楽]
寝てもいいですか
なんか暇強くなったな
怒っちゃったかな
許してくれますか
次から気をつけろって
[音楽]
ブリーチしてから
髪の毛がなかなか乾きませんどうしたら
いいですか
やばいマジでなんかやばい
左から
めちゃくちゃ
[音楽]
目線を感じるこれはこの
景色は
ろうそくを持って
前を見てればいいんですよ
[音楽]
ね儀式の穴をつけますよ俺は
[拍手]
怒ってる
ルールに繋がってます
[音楽]
いつもアメリカで
お仕事されてる
ありがとうございました
[音楽]
食べて帰ってください
おすすめはあんな
子です
3つ
わかんないのがやばい
どうしようどうしようどうしようどう
しよう結構やばい
これすごいな精神的に
だいぶ苦しい
やばい
精神崩壊しそうです
背筋が凍る
扇風機が落ちまして
一番笑える何で扇風機犯されてんだろう
[音楽]
終わった終わりましたお疲れ様でした
はいというわけでこれで儀式は終了です
最後にロウソクの日を扇風機で消して
終わりです最後まで気を抜かずにやって
いきましょう
決していいのが本当に行きますよ行きます
終了です
よかった
バカで
ます
[音楽]
ただいま元気ですね
はいというわけでこれで儀式は終わりです
もう片付けたら5時近くになりました外は
もう明るいですこれねーこれ
術というかなんかもう
精神攻撃がすごいですねあのね3時半まで
寝れるわけがないんですよマジでずっと
震えてたしもうなんか物音とかしたりし
たら普通にきついし突然雨が降るし
バーンって音も聞こえたし動画で撮れて
たらいいんですけどなんか
精神的ダメージがすごかったですね
メンタルマジできついまあこれ何でやる
かって言うと質問に答えてくれるっていう
いわゆるコックにさんとかビジャ版って
いうやつの上位互換らしいですねイタコと
か恒例術ができない人一般人用に高齢者が
できる
装置的な儀式であるらしいですいやーもう
寒気が鳥肌がマジで止まらないんですよ
もう
ろうそくの日が消えなかったりなんか
大きな
失敗がなかったので無事終わったんです
けど例えば儀式を行っててその名前呼んで
も反応がない本当に反応がないとかって
スマホとか携帯に電話をして相手に気づか
せたりとかやめる方法も色んなパターンが
あるので結構難しい
儀式だったみたいです
是非海外版画でもスリーキング
ス
責任は負いませんじゃあ
[音楽]
これが最後のジャーナになることは誰も
予知していなかっ